[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cameron kinley former navy cornerback
i'll give you the backstory here
went undrafted team captain he's the
class president gave the commencement
speech at the naval academy
had an outside chance to win a roster
spot with the buccaneers
he would be a special teamer maybe a
fifth cornerback there
the chiefs also had an interest in him
as well
and cameron told the tampa bay times he
chose the buccaneers due to a family
connection
to coaches in the organization his
father was a college teammate
of one of the assistant coaches on the
roster
and uh his older brother played under
bruce aryans with the cardinals so he
was going to try out
for the tampa bay buccaneers and see if
he could make it as
their fifth cornerback as special teams
guy but the naval academy said no
to his request he was never trying to
just leave the naval academy
he knew he still had his military
commitment he was going to try to defer
that
and cameron kinley joining us on the uh
program here
uh tell me the the process here though
of trying to play in the nfl with that
military commitment what steps did you
try to take to join the buccaneers
right so in the summer of 2019 president
trump endorsed
this new policy which is called the dtm
which allows service academy
graduates to request to delay their
commission in order to pursue
professional support so you put together
a package and your school
signs off on the package and forwards it
to the secretary of defense
so after i was uh picked up by the tampa
bay buccaneers
uh we got our my package together and
then the naval academy signed off on it
and forwarded it to the uh secretary of
defense and then
it was denied by the acting secretary of
the navy
what reason were you given i was given
no explanation and i was told that there
was no appeal process
is that why you're doing the interview
you could say that i just want to kind
of get my story
out there uh because i feel like it
needs to be heard for sure
um but yeah it's definitely it's
definitely been a tough couple of weeks
trying to deal with the situation
are you allowed to ask for an
explanation
well that's kind of the business that
we're in in the military you know i
don't
i'm not owed an explanation of the
acting secretary of the navy
simply it was up to his discretion um to
deny the package and not afford it
that's just a part of the way the dtm
works so
he doesn't owe me an explanation it
would be nice to have one and just give
me a sense of peace but
at the end of the day i'm not really
expecting one what kind of emotions do
you have
i remember when i found out i was
speechless you know i felt like i had a
piece of me taken away i just thought
about all the hard work and all the
adversity that i had to overcome to
get to this point and for someone to
just take away my childhood dream
it definitely hurts you know and it's
emotions that i'm still processing
i woke up this morning and i just felt
kind of sick head heavy
uh so it's definitely starting to take a
toll on
[Music]
what did you uh hear from the buccaneers
um so my agents have been doing a lot of
the communication with the team
so if things can get figured out by
training cap
then they'll take me back if not then in
two years
uh i'll be able to go back and try out
as long as i'm still
on the military reserve list have you
reached out to keenan reynolds
uh he sent me a uh well he tweeted
something now just telling me to keep my
head up and
stay positive and that he feels for me
uh but i haven't really talked to
too many other people who had success um
with the military and professional
sports
yeah cameron it seems random it you know
maybe you're not enough a high enough
profile
uh you know keenan keenan was pretty
famous you know people thought maybe he
was a heisman trophy
uh guy so i don't know if if if it's
that
that uh if you you know david robinson
famously
was able to go to the nba but he was
high profile and it reflected
uh in a positive way on the naval
academy i so i i'm just trying to
process this
as well can you understand this or help
me understand
why one guy and not you well i don't
think the profile has anything to do
with it because i look at last year
there are four undrafted players from
other academies that were able to use
this
uh package and then this year alone
there's also
three players from air force and a
player from army who all went undrafted
uh that have been able to use this
policy and during the whole draft
process you know i was able to i was
fortunate enough to have different
interviews with
good morning football and espn you know
so i felt like i was bringing
good publicity to the navy and to the
naval academy
um and then i went down to ricky minicap
and had a good performance down there so
i don't think the profile has anything
to do with it uh i'll be curious to
figure out
what's the next step so i'm getting
ready to um
i'm preparing for my career as a officer
in the navy now
i'm currently on my basket leave and
that expires on june 28th
and then i head to annapolis for a
temporary duties
uh duty assignment until october and
then after that i'll start my career
path
as an information warfare community
officer you need tom brady on your side
here cameron
that'd be nice if i could get uh tv 12
to say something i definitely appreciate
that
but i understand are you worried about
uh any repercussions during
this interview it might happen you know
uh but at the end of the day i know
where my heart is and i know where i
stand i feel like the the common
misconception is that
i don't want to serve and that's never
been the case has never ever been the
case since i've been at the academy or
else i would have transferred you know
i'm i'm excited to serve as an officer
in the navy and i'm looking forward to
that career
i just felt like i had the opportunity
to do both and i don't see why uh
i'm not able to how many push-ups can
you do right now
i mean i'm still in shape i i don't know
the exact number but
if it's a competition i keep going
if i said a hundred yeah i can i can
knock out a hundred
hundred
uh i didn't mean to insult you of course
you could do a hundred yeah
i understand that uh good luck with the
fight here cameron we appreciate it
we'll be following this
and um um you know i wish you well
because i
i i can understand the frustration there
if you you think you got something
and you still want to commit to the
military and then it was taken away from
you so
uh good luck with the next step whatever
that is
yes sir thank you for having me on the
show it's cameron kinley former navy
cornerback went undrafted and uh was
trying to make the tampa bay buccaneers
where